what does it mean to be normal and what
does it mean to be sick I've asked
myself this question from the time I was
about seven when I was diagnosed with
Tourette's syndrome Tourette's is a
neurological disorder characterized by
stereotyped movements I perform against
my will called tics now taiks are
technically involuntary in the sense
that they occur without any conscious
attention or intention on my part but
there's a funny thing about how I
experience tics they feel more
unvoluntary than involuntary because I
still feel like it's me moving my
shoulder not some external force also I
get this uncomfortable sensation called
premonitory ordered right before tics
happen and particularly when I'm trying
to resist them now I imagine most of you
out there
understand what I'm saying but unless
you have Tourette's you probably think
you can't relate but I bet you can so
let's try a little experiment here and
see if I can give you a taste of what my
experience feels like alright ready
don't blink no really don't blink and
besides dry ice what do you feel phantom
pressure eyelids tingling a need are you
holding your breath uh-huh that's
approximately what my tics feel like now
tics and blinking neurologically
speaking are not the same but my point
is is that you don't have to have
Tourette's to be able to relate to my
experience of my premonitory urges
because your brain can give you similar
experiences and feelings so let's shift
the conversation from what it means to
be normal versus sick to what it means
that a majority of us
are both normal and sick because in the
final analysis we're all humans whose
brains provide for a spectrum of
experiences and everything on that
spectrum of human experiences is
ultimately produced by brain systems
that assume a spectrum of different
states so again what does it mean to be
normal
and what does it mean to be sick when
sickness exists on the extreme end of a
spectrum of normal as both a researcher
who studies differences and how
individuals brains wire and rewire
themselves and as a torretta with other
related diagnoses I have long been
fascinated by failures of
self-regulation on the impulsive and
compulsive behavioral spectrums because
so much of my own experience of my own
body and my own behavior has existed all
over that map so with the spotlight on
the opioid crisis I really found myself
wondering lately where on the spectrum
of unvoluntary behavior do we put
something like abusing opioid
painkillers or heroin by now we all know
that the opioid crisis an epidemic is
out of control
ninety-one people die every day in this
country from overdose and between 2002
and 2015 the number of deaths from
heroin increased by a factor of six and
something about the way that we treat
addiction isn't working at least not for
everyone it is a fact that people
suffering from addiction have lost free
will when it comes to their behavior
around drugs alcohol food or other
reward systems stimulating behaviors
that addiction is a brain based disease
State is a medical neurobiological
reality
but how we relate to that disease indeed
how we relate to the concept of disease
when it comes to addiction makes an
enormous difference for how we treat
people with addictions so we tend to
think of pretty much everything we do is
entirely voluntary but it turns out that
the brain's default state is really more
like a car idling and drive than a car
in park some of what we think we choose
to do is actually things that we have
become programmed to do when the brakes
are released
have you ever joked that your brain was
running on autopilot well guess what it
probably was okay and the brain's
autopilot is in a structure called the
striatum so the striatum detects
emotional and sensory motor conditions
and it triggers it knows to trigger
whatever behavior you have done most
often in the past under those same
conditions do you know why I became a
neuroscientist because I wanted to learn
what made me tick thank you thank you
I've been wanting to use that one in
front of an audience for years so in
graduate school I studied genetics
actors that orchestrate wiring to the
striatum during development and yes that
is my former license plate for the
record I don't recommend any PhD student
get a license plate with their thesis
topic printed on it unless they're
prepared for their experiments not to
work for the next two years I eventually
did figure it out
so my experiments were exploring how mis
wiring in the striatum relates to
compulsive behaviors meaning behaviors
that are coerced by uncomfortable urges
you can't consciously resist
so I was really excited when my mice
developed this compulsive behavior where
they were rubbing their faces and they
couldn't seem to stop even when they
were wounding themselves okay excited is
the wrong wrong word okay
I I actually felt I felt terrible for
them I thought that they had tics
evidence of striatum is wearing and they
were compulsive but it turned out on
further testing that these mice showed
an aversion to interacting and getting
to know other unfamiliar mice which was
unusual it was unexpected
the results implied that the striatum
which for sure is involved in compulsive
spectrum disorders is also involved in
human social connection and our ability
to not human social connection but our
ability to connect so why don't deeper
into a field called social neuroscience
and that is a newer interdisciplinary
field and there I found reports that
linked the striatum not just to social
anomalies in mice but also in people as
it turns out the social neural chemistry
in the striatum is linked to things
you've probably already heard of like
oxytocin which is that hormone that
makes cuddling feel all warm and fuzzy
but it also implicates signaling at
opioid receptors there are naturally
occurring opioids in your brain that are
deeply linked to social processes
experiments with naloxone which block
opioid receptors show us just how
essential this opioid receptor signaling
is to social interaction when people are
given naloxone it's an ingredient in
narcan that reverses opioid overdoses to
save lives but when it's given to
healthy people it actually interfered
with their ability to feel connected to
people they already knew
and cared about okay so something about
not having opioid receptor binding makes
it difficult for us to feel the rewards
of social interaction now for the
interest of time I've necessarily gotten
rid of some of the scientific details
but briefly here's where we're at
the effects of social disconnection
through opioid receptors the effects of
addictive drugs and the effects of
abnormal neurotransmission on
involuntary movements and compulsive
behaviors all converge in the striatum
and the striatum an opioid signaling in
it has been deeply linked with
loneliness okay when we don't have
enough signaling at opioid receptors we
can feel alone in a room full of people
we care about and love who love us
social neuroscientists like dr. Petch
chiapoe at the University of Chicago
have discovered that loneliness is very
dangerous and it predisposes people to
entire spectrums of physical and mental
illnesses think of it like this when
you're your hungriest pretty much any
food tastes amazing right so similarly
loneliness creates a hunger in the brain
which hypersensitive neural chemically
high percentages our reward system and
social isolation acts through receptors
for these naturally occurring opioids
and other social neurotransmitters to
leave the striatum in a state where its
response to things that signal reward
and pleasure is completely completely
over-the-top and in this state of
hypersensitivity our brains signal deep
dissatisfaction we become Restless
irritable and impulsive and that's
pretty much what I want you to keep the
bowl of Halloween chocolate entirely
across the room for me because I will
eat it all I will and that brings up
another thing that makes
social disconnection so dangerous if we
don't have the ability to connect
socially we are so ravenous for our
social neuro chemistry to be rebalanced
we're likely to seek relief from
anywhere and if that anywhere is opioid
painkillers or heroin it is going to be
a heat-seeking missile for our social
reward system is it any wonder people in
today's world are becoming addicted so
easily social isolation excuse me
contributes to relapse studies have
shown that people who tend to avoid
relapse tend to be people who have broad
reciprocal social relationships where
they can be of service to each other
where they can be helpful being of
service lets people connect so if we
don't have the ability to authentically
connect our society increasingly lacks
this ability to authentically connect
and experience things that are
transcendent and beyond ourselves we
used to get this transcendence from a
feeling of belonging to our families in
our communities but everywhere
communities are changing and social and
economic disintegration is making this
harder and harder I'm not the only
person to point out that the areas in
the country most economically hard-hit
where people feel most desolate about
their life's meaning are also the places
where there have been communities most
ravaged by opioids social isolation acts
through the brain's reward system to
make this state of affairs literally
painful so perhaps it's this pain this
loneliness
this despondence that's driving so many
of us to connect with whatever we can
like food like handheld electronics and
for too many people to drugs like heroin
and fentanyl I know someone who
overdosed who was revived by narcan and
she was mostly angry that she wasn't
simply allowed to die imagine for a
second how that feels that state of
hopelessness okay but the striatum is
also a source of hope because the
striatum gives us a clue of how to bring
people back so remember that the
striatum is our autopilot running our
behaviors on habit and it's possible to
rewire to reprogram that autopilot but
it involves neuroplasticity so
neuroplasticity is the ability of brains
to reprogram themselves and rewire
themselves to the we can learn new
things and maybe you've heard the
classic adage of plasticity neurons that
fire together wire together all right so
we need to practice social connective
behaviors instead of compulsive
behaviors when we're lonely when we are
queued to remember our drug we needed
neuronal firing repeated experiences in
order for the striatum to undergo that
necessary neuroplasticity that it allows
it to take that go find heroin autopilot
offline and with the convergence of
social neuroscience addiction and
compulsive spectrum disorders in the
striatum suggest is that it's not simply
enough to teach the striatum healthier
responses to compulsive urges we need
social impulses to replace drug hewed
compulsive behaviors because we need to
rebalance neurochemically our social
reward system and unless that happens
we're going to be left in a state of
craving no matter what besides our drug
we repeatedly practice doing
I believe that the solution to the
opioid crisis is to explore how social
and psycho-spiritual interventions can
act as neuro technologies in circuits
that process social and drug-induced
rewards one possibility is to create and
study scalable tools for people to
connect with one another over a mutual
interest in recovery through
psycho-spiritual practices and as such
psycho-spiritual practice could involve
anything from people getting together as
mega fans of touring jam bands or
parkour jams
featuring shared experiences of
vulnerability and personal growth or
more conventional things like recovery
yoga meetups or meetings centered around
more traditional conceptions of
spiritual experiences but whatever it is
it needs to activate all of the
neurotransmitter systems in the striatum
better involved in processing social
connection social media can't go deep
enough for this social media doesn't so
much encourage us to share as it does to
compare it's the difference between
having superficial small talk with
someone and a CENTAC deeply connected
conversation with eye contact and stigma
also keeps us separate there's a lot of
evidence that it keeps us sick and
stigma often makes it safer for addicts
to connect with other addicts but
recovery groups centered around
reestablishing social connections could
certainly be inclusive of people who are
seeking recovery for a range of mental
health problems my point is when we
connect around what's broken we connect
as human beings we heal ourselves from
the compulsive self-destruction that was
our response to the pain of
disconnection when we think of
neuropsychiatric illnesses as a spectrum
of phenomenon that are
part of what make us human then we
remove the other nests of people who
struggle with self-destruction we remove
the stigma between doctors and patients
and caregivers we put the question of
what it means to be normal versus sick
back on the spectrum of the human
condition and it is on that spectrum
where we can all connect and seek
healing together for all of our
struggles with humaneness thank you for
letting me share
[Applause]